[Music]
sharks are the ocean's primary predators
eating every fish in their path but what
if you ended up in a pool full of them
and you were the prey what would happen
when they smelled your blood what are
your chances of surviving and how
dangerous are these sharks this is what
if and here's what would happen if you
fell into a pool full of sharks if by
some stroke of bad luck you happen to
end up in a massive pool filled with a
bunch of sharks here's what you should
do if you fall into the pool during
broad daylight you might be in luck
generally speaking sharks feed at dusk
or during the night so they'll be less
likely to want a munch on you during the
day once you're in the water though the
first thing you need to do is remain
calm and not make any sudden movements
not easy I know but you're not going to
out swim a shark so what do you do if
one comes right for you first let's put
shark attacks into perspective they are
incredibly rare and you're more likely
to get struck by lightning than to get
eaten by a shark believe it or not the
fact that you're a human is incredibly
helpful you might think it would be
easier if you were a fish so you'd be
able to blend in but that's not the case
you see despite what movies might tell
you sharks don't want to eat you sharks
are wired to eat other fish and not
animals they don't know about and if
you're an average-sized human you're a
lot bigger than most sharks too a lot of
them you might look like something that
could hurt them the only real exception
could be a great white shark
they're bigger than humans and not as
likely to be afraid of us but just like
other sharks they're generally only
interested in the eating other fish
marine biologists believe most shark
attacks are from humans appearing as
fish in the water a surfers leg dangling
off their surfboard might look like a
seal to some sharks especially in rapid
waters so as long as you look like a
human you should be okay but what if
they smell your blood even if they do
they may still not eat you it would be a
scent they're not used to and the Sharks
might not be interested in you you're
more likely to be eaten if the Sharks
hear that you're in pain in addition to
having an amazing sense of smell
sharks can also hear incredibly well
that's how they catch a lot of their
prey so if a shark hears you in pain
they might quickly come towards you but
that's no guarantee that the shark is
going to eat you sharks aren't vicious
by nature but they are very curious if
they notice you they might want to see
you up close if this happens
don't be afraid they probably just want
to see who's in their home if they do
bite you they might not even know that
they're hurting you
you see shark's teeth are like our hands
they're what they use to investigate the
world so you may get bitten not because
the shark wants to hurt you but by
accident one way you might get eaten is
if these sharks in the pool aren't being
fed at all then you'll be trapped with
some ravenous sharks desperate for food
if you somehow manage to avoid being
eaten by starving sharks you'll quickly
realize how beautiful swimming with
sharks can be now what if sharks weren't
even something you had to worry about
because they all went extinct well that
sounds like a story for
another what-if
[Music]